Different emotions are expressed differently on the face and in our voice. Each
emotion has its own unique combination of facial muscles and voice changes
often involving pitch. Let's take fear for example. This involves the eyebrows
being lifted and pulled together and the upper eyelids are also lifted. And the
lips are stretched and pulled apart. Anger, on the other hand, the eyebrows are
lowered and pulled together. The eye lids are tightened and the lips are
thinned and pressed together. One interesting application of analyzing facial
expressions of emotion. Is being able to distinguish which emotion is being
expressed based strictly on muscle movements. We know, or we think we know what
someone's feeling, just by their face. They tell us when they're sad, angry,
disgusted or happy just with their face. And as it turns out, sometimes we can
be fooled. A happy face is not always a genuinely happy face. There are in fact
differences in the muscle movements of a true smile, and a social smile, or a
fake smile.